el país donde la seguridad y el temor
convergen los salvadoreños cumplen un
año desde el inicio de la guerra contra
las pandillas muchos de los habitantes
celebran mejores condiciones de
seguridad en sus calles
una vida de otra mejor que esa la
seguridad que está hoy porque
anteriormente
era difícil sobrevivir
salía bueno no sabía si volvía a llegar
a regresar a la casa otra vez fue el 27
de marzo del 2022 cuando el gobierno
estableció un régimen de excepción como
respuesta a 87 homicidios perpetrados
durante tres días y aunque la versión
oficial es el combate el crimen
organizado medios locales revelaron que
la violencia fue el resultado de la
ruptura de un pacto secreto entre el
gobierno y las pandillas según cifras
oficiales la medida ha dejado más de
60.000 pandilleros detenidos pero
organismos locales reportan más de 3.000
detenciones arbitrarias incluso
denuncian que 72 personas murieron en
custodia del Estado hay jóvenes que
están en las cárceles que no están sin
hacer nada sin haber cometido un delito
Simplemente porque iban en las calles
porque le cayó mal al policía al soldado
se lo llevaron
amnistía internacional y otros
organismos critican los métodos del
presidente nayib bukele cuya campaña de
seguridad le da puntos en las encuestas
Pero dentro de las presiones algunos
funcionarios creen que las pandillas no
están desarticuladas y que podrían
actuar en venganza en cualquier momento